foreign
you've had a ringside seat both as an in
one you experiment on yourself and
countless patients we all end up dead
but many of us die long before they coat
it they code us and many of us live less
than our best up in these last days so
can you talk about the four horsemen
what you're what you even mean by all
that
well I mean the the four horsemen are
just referenced to kind of the the four
big chronic diseases that you know
shorten lifespan which is a part of
longevity the other part being Health
span which I'm sure we'll talk about as
well
um
but you know for the most part if you're
over 40 and you're a non-smoker and you
don't engage in really really Ultra
risky behavior
um unfortunately that includes you know
using you know illicit drugs now given
fentanyl uh poisoning
um there's pretty much a 80 plus percent
chance you're gonna succumb to one of
these Horsemen cardiovascular disease
neurodegenerative disease cancer and
metabolic disease the most obvious
example of this is type 2 diabetes but
of course long before you get to type 2
diabetes you've passed through the
station of non-alcoholic fatty liver
disease insulin resistance
hyperinsulinemia and so collectively uh
at least one way to think about how do I
live longer is understanding what are
the impediments to a longer life and for
most of us it's going to be one of the
horsemen
so it's a moment of shame that I carry
around with me
um I spent 20 years working in higher ed
with scientists and professors as a dean
of students as a professor
I spent my years with some of the most
lovely caring wonderful people who are
trying to solve big problems
and when I left that ecosystem if you
will and came here and as my 12 year old
son says Dad you're just a YouTuber now
as I transitioned to this new ecosystem
I've been
frustrated humbled whatever word you
want to say
by the fact that I was talking over
people for 20 years
um as as quote unquote as we tried to
dumb things down or put things on the
bottom shelf where people understand I I
just was talking over people and it
wasn't until I was sitting with single
moms and truck drivers who just want to
be better dads
um just want to be better moms that I
realized man this this is such there's
such a a Chasm here
how do we bridge that Chasm between like
what even is metabolic disease and the
single mom with three kids who's just
trying to say dude can you just give me
one or two things so I can breathe right
what this feels like such a gap there
and I don't know how to bridge it
I don't know that I have the answer to
that John I mean I think
I would say the way to bridge it is to
uh in a resource confined world and for
most people the most precious resource
is time not money so the question is
how much time does it take to reduce
risk of these things and and
you know live you know take take action
today to have more time later I mean
that's basically what you're doing here
it's it's a Time swap so you're and it
is an Arbitrage in your favor so the the
more time you can put into this thing
now the more absolute time you get on
the back end and the better that quality
of time I think most people care more
about the quality piece than the
absolute piece I think
if most people were really confronted
with
what it means to suffer in quality of
life cognitive suffer physical suffer
um
they would accept that it's a really
worthwhile decision to make when you
still have your health to do something
about it
and you know what one does about it is a
function of how much time a person has
but you know you have to compare it to
the alternative right so
if a person is exercising not at all
right which is more more people than not
are not exercising at all
um that's the lowest piece of hanging
fruit there is out there I mean going
from nothing to three hours a week of
exercise
Cuts your risk of all cause mortality
meaning death of any cause certainly
inclusive of the horsemen cuts that risk
down by 50 percent in any given yearly I
mean we just don't have other things
that compare to that so there there is
no drug on the market on planet earth
that could touch that
no not even close so so you know I'm not
going to be the one that sits here and
says that is or isn't worth it but but
those are just the facts and I I don't I
don't see it as my my job frankly to to
to to tell people what to do I I think
it's just I'd like to lay out the info
and let people decide how much of the
menu they want